همم الى فرنسا حيث شهدت العاصمه باريس
اليوم مظاهرات للجاليه الكرديه احتجاجا
على مقتل ثلاثه من ابنائها برصاص مسلح امس
وحمل المتظاهرون لافته اشار فيها الى ان
الهجوم وقع قبل ايام من الذكرى العاشره
لمقتلته نشطاء اكراد في باريس في تاسع من
يناير كانون الثاني عام 2013
وهذه الصوره الان تاتينا مباشره من
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس
وهذه المظاهره للجاليه الكرديه كما ذكرنا
همم تعبير عن غضب الجاهليه من الهجوم الذي
تعرض له همم افرادها امام المركز الثقفي
في الكوردي
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس والذي قتل على
اثره اشخاص من الجاهليه واصابه عدد اخر
وقد حدث بالامس همم الشبكات وصدامات بين
الشرطه الفرنسيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كعكه
اثر غضبا اكثر لان كثير من الاكراد
رفضوا وصفا العمليه بالعنصريه وقالوا انها
ارهابيه للمزيد التفاصيل وكما يبدو في
صوره خلف زميل همم حافظ مريبه المزيد
التفاصيل حول هذه المظاهره لانه بين حافظ
مريم من باريس وواضحه اعلام الكرديه وصور
زعيم عبد الله اوجلان والغضب والذي عبر
عنه افراد الجاليه والمدينه تفاصيل معك
حافظ
[موسيقى]
نعم عبد الصمد بالفعل كما قلت غضب كبير
نلمسه هنا لدى الجاليه الكرديه التي يشارك
طيف هام منها في هذه المظاهره كما نشاهد
خلفي الان ثمه اعلام كرديه كثيره مرفوعه
بالاضافه الى صور الزعيم الكردي عبد الله
اوجلان خطابات حماسيه في الحقيقه نسمعها
هنا للتنجيد
بالهجوم الذي يصفه الحاضرون هنا بالارهابي
الذي استهدف الجاليه الكرديه ولكن ايضا
للتعبير عن غضب هؤلاء الذين نشاهدهم هنا
والالاف الاخرين من الاكراد هنا في فرنسا
عما يعتبرونه تقصيرا من السلطات في حمايه
جانتهم لاسيه ما هو انهم يقولون انهم
من اهل السلطات الفرنسيه مزيدا من الحمايه
للجاليه الكرديه ولما قراتها مثل مقر همم
الثقافي المركز الثقافي الكردي هذا خصوصا
مع الثراب همم مع اقتراب ذكر همم قتل
ثلاثه ناشطين اكراد وسط العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس هذا
الاحتجاج او هذا التجمع الاحتجاجي دعى له
المجلس الديمقراطي الذي يضم اكثر من 24
جمعيه كرديه هنا في فرنسا هؤلاء يقولون ان
الهجوم ارهابي ودوافعه سياسيه الى حد الان
الابحاث ما زالت متواصله مع منفذ هذا
الهجوم الذي اعترف
للمحققين لان الدوافع التي دفعته لتنفيذ
هذا الهجوم هي همم لانه عنصر كما قال
لرجال الشرطه اا ولكن ما زالت الابحاث
متواصله قال ايضا بحسب مصادر قبائيه انه
استهدف الجاريه الكرديه تحديدا دون ايضاح
اكثر دوافع او ما الذي دفعه اكثر للقيام
بهذا الهجوم ما تم الكشف عنه ان المهاجم
كان بحوزته عدد من المخازن المعباه
بالخراطيش التي لم يستخدمها لحسن الحظ كما
قال شهود عيان وكما قالت مصادر ايضا من
الشرطه الفرنسيه وهو يبلغ من العمر 69
عاما وكان قد ارتكب منذ سنه تحديدا هجوما
بالسيف على مخيم اللاجئين هنا في باريس تم
يخافه على مدى سنه كامله وتم تسريحه من
السجن في انتظار محاكمته منذ ايام فقط
ليعود ورتكب هذه الجريمه التي يقول
الحاضرون هنا بانها جريمه ارهابيه يذكر
بان
اعضاء همم القضاء ما زال يبحث في هذه
العمليه ولم يتم تكييف هذه الجريمه على
انها جريمه همم ارهابيه او جريمه عنصريه
وفق الثعابير القانونيه التي يتم
استخدامها عاده هنا في فرنسا في الحقيقه
هذا الهجوم سبب جدلا وغضبا ايضا لدى
الطبقه السياسيه الفرنسيه خصوصا لدى
الاطياف اليساريه التي اعتبرت ان ما وقع
الان هو نتيجه لما تصفه هذه الجهات
السياسيه اليسريه بانه تساهل مع التطرف
اليميني ومع اليمين المتطرف ومع الخطابات
العنصريه التي تستهدف الاجانب والمهاجرين
على مدى سنوات
نعم الماضيه وان ما وقع امس هو نتيجه لكل
هذا التساهل على حد تعبيرهم مع الخطابات
العنصريه والارهابيه والمعاديه للمهاجرين
في فرنسا
من ساحه الجمهوريه في العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس شكرا